this is every transmuter and Hunter
Hunter ranked by a man on the internet
and we are going to start with the
Undisputed queen of transmutation as
well as scantily clad men's magazine
Enthusiast so first up transmutation is
a fairly simple Affinity it's the
practice of changing your raw Aura into
a substance and in the case of biscuit
she transmutes Aura into a super lotion
which is then used for massage purposes
sounds a bit underwhelming at first but
a 30 minute massage can have the same
effect on the body that eight hours of
sleep achieves it relieves both physical
and mental fatigue so not so
underwhelming anymore because her
abilities could theoretically eliminate
the need for sleep you could live a
whole third more of life than other
people with the same time as them
however the real life hack being used by
biskey here is that the special
transmuted lotion restores more Aura
than it costs to activate the ability so
biscuit is well and truly worked out how
to invest her Aura in order to pay nen
dividends or perhaps even dividends
she's worked out how to completely cheat
life through her transmutation and some
clever restrictions I mean if you want
to call being massaged by a cute nangone
named cookie a restriction and I suppose
if you were to put the ability into an
equation that it would look like massage
benefits equal Aura equals lotion times
cookie minus time there is also the body
transformation which we won't Linger on
because that well that's something of a
net Enigma and it doesn't matter for our
purposes here anyway because with the
massage alone misky is an easy stier
transmuter also this video is sponsored
by facta fresh ready-made meals
delivered straight to your doorstep
these things are like a lifesaver for me
I don't have the time to cook and I love
that facto removes all of the Annoying
Parts like meal planning and prepping
the convenience is unparalleled whilst
also providing no-nonsense delicious
food that also meets your nutritional
needs also absolutely most underrated
benefit No Mess no dishes to wash no
pots to soak no realizing that you've
run out of dishwashing liquid again Liam
and also no potato peelers to
meticulously remove all the crap from
everything is ready to eat within two
minutes and cleaned up in a mere
fraction of that time use my link or go
to
go.factor75.com and use code POG new
work use code that one the one on screen
for 50 off your first box and once you
click my description live update to
count up the purchases so do that thing
but for now it's back to you me in stark
contrast Miss Kruger we now have feitan
who transmutes pain into well more pain
I mean not exactly more accurately an
ability like Rising Sun could be
described as painful output equals Aura
times damage taken and because the
Restriction is just a little bit more
costly than receiving a delightsome
massage the output is significantly
higher the raw power generated by Rising
Sun alone would put Big Bang characters
like UV again to shame get in get in the
corner of again the shame corner and I
like that even though we didn't see
feitan in action until the Chimera
antarct this ability was seeded through
his love of administering torture it's
implied that feitan has other abilities
as well but it doesn't matter as rising
sun alone shows that feitan is a supreme
transmuter and belongs nowhere but the
S2 for a new face now here's Hanzo a man
who was recently labeled a transmute to
buy yoshihiro tagashi in the exhibition
memo to be honest I'm a little surprised
that it actually took this long to to
find out hanzo's Affinity because he
never shuts up about his secrets in fact
the best word to describe Hanzo is
loquacious which is essentially a nice
way of saying he talks he he talks a lot
you ever need to tell someone to very
politely shut up and just say my you're
rather loquacious today and they'll
probably take it as a compliment because
they're unlikely to know what it means
but also too proud to actually ask what
it means so I'll just go yes I will say
that this Revelation is exceptionally
unfortunate for Hanzo at the moment
because as with a lot of tagashi's
strange Revelations transmutation goes
against hanzo's current skill set as
demonstrated the ability we have seen is
hanzo's skill number four which creates
an astrally projected end clone through
the powers of conjuration and
manipulation potentially even a mission
instead of conjuration but if that were
the case then that would just make Hanzo
an even worse transmuter because
emission is further away than
conjuration on the nen ring so to put
the efficacy into some perspective
hanzo's equation would look like Hanzo
skill number four equals Aura times
conjuration plus Aura times manipulation
which comes at the cost of 0.8 and 0.4
respect actively so if there was one
unit of origin each then two units of R
invested would result in 1.2 units of
output it's not great but it does give
Hanzo the skill he needs and you don't
necessarily need to use Aura at its most
efficient to be a great nen user and
that's what Hanzo is he is a great nen
user unfortunately from what we know
he's a transmuter who doesn't actually
transmute which means that we have no
choice but to open up the Castro tier
quite early a special place reserved for
nen users who almost if not completely
deny their own affinities hanzo's exam
metisoka however is on the complete
opposite end of the spectrum and is
potentially the greatest example of a
pure transmuto isoka is like some sort
of nen piano with a single key because
he is very one note hisoka what's that
on your fingers bungee gum hisoka what
are you sticking under your desk Bungie
gum hisoka what are you using to
sodomize that young child text your
surprise oh well at least it isn't the
surprise is that it's bungee gum and to
be fair it works hisoka operates at
almost 100 Aura efficiency at any given
time he is the transmutally old dream of
being as well as the person we will
dream of never encountering in some sort
of dark alley or even a fully lit alley
and his net equation is as follows
bungee gum equals Aura plus intelligence
times arousal I hope you're writing all
of these down by the way there will be a
test hisoka extracts the absolute most
from his transmutation and applies it
nigh on flawlessly which is why the S
tier isn't even good enough for him and
we are going to have to open up an
unprecedented gum tier next up is the
boy who failed the hunter exam but
succeeded in winning our hearts quite
literally in the case of Jonas and just
look at killer was sticking his little
pinky up as if he's serving tea to the
queen on a on a high-class assassin boy
but really kilowatt is the very model of
Excellence he has never failed at
anything except for gambling he's he's
really bad at gambling and he receives
four marks for choosing the most
difficult volatile and rapidly or
consuming substance he possibly could to
transmute into electricity the ultimate
Optimist really turning all of his
horrific childhood torture into his
greatest weapon and we do have the
Restriction of needing to be charged all
the time so kiloware is very much that
friend who always has less than 10 on
their phone for reasons that nobody else
can comprehend except that kilowatt is
also the phone itself but hey that is
still a bargain price to pay for the
output kilowatt is a marvelous
combination of raw talent sharp thinking
and hard training all of which will
reward him as an s-tier transmuter for
some more Phantom troops shenanigan Ray
here's marchy say hello to Machi she
enjoys string as well as long walks in
the dark on her own plotting the brutal
brutal murder of hisoka her
transmutation is actually quite rare
because it gives you the illusion of a
physical object being transmuted that
would usually be the realm of
conjuration but this is because Machi is
actually a dual Affinity wielder sitting
right between transmutation and
enhancement on the nenrik so she crafts
the string substance and then enhances
it to the point where one meter of
string could lift one ton of weight and
the longer the strings go the less
effective they become allegedly she
could create a string strong enough to
circumnavigate the globe but it would
snap when confronted by even a gentle
breeze incredibly versatile though and
Machi is actually the first known Troop
but to become a nen user having been
taught by a mysterious embalmer named
renko furthermore despite her sparse and
really rather subtle appearances in the
actual series marchy is one of the
favorite characters of the hunter hunter
mumbaga card game with variant including
Santa marchy wedding marchy and of
course provocative fantasy police woman
marchy there is a Machi for every
occasion but despite a very effective
ability and well thought out
restrictions Machi is a distinct grade
below many of the other transmuters
we've already mentioned and so she will
be receiving a solid a and now I'd like
to bring your attention to montverde
that's a liar I don't want to bring
anyone's attention to Mud Vera I don't
even know if I'm pronouncing that name
correctly to be honest with you but he
is a transmuter so we do need to talk a
transmuter who desperately desperately
wishes he was an emitter incredibly
inexperienced incredibly underqualified
and possessing of incredibly shockingly
big lips now to some other people that
might be a point in his favor for for
other reasons but it definitely doesn't
help with transmutation I think and so
he is getting kicked straight in the
castros until further notice so let's go
Blends our palette with men's
so fun fact I actually have it in the
script to mispronounce his name but I I
wasn't trying to that just happened this
is why we as a fan base all agree to
just call him yupi although he is often
considered the least intelligent of the
royal guard up is certainly the member
who delved deepest into how best to make
nen work for his own personal needs
Peter makes all sorts of whimsical and
not at all well thought out abilities
meanwhile Poof's net Evolution doesn't
exist and shirepoof was just kind of
overpowered and a bit stagnant from the
gecko but we see yupi's Nan Evolution
happen in real time like feitan with
pain up harnesses the power of Rage
which he even takes a step further than
feitan by managing to harness his rage
into a more condensed form and after
acquiring the ability meruem then
perfects it by channeling all of this
devastating power into a singular clean
beam also here's a really weird faction
yupi and shyapoof are the only two
Chimera ants to have five fingers ten in
total five a new chant which I find
especially odd because up is composed of
Khan mirror ant and magical beasts there
is theoretically no human in his DNA and
yet he ends up looking like one of the
most human Chimera ants but due to
significantly outclassing even the St
transmuters we have no choice but to
give hisoku a roommate in the newly
established gum tier this is a very very
top heavy tier list so far transmuters
apparently just do not effer around but
here is the most important character
that many of you will never even have
heard of primarily because he's not in
the actual series but his name is
mauritonio a circus director and the man
who taught hisoka nen allegedly he
appears in the One-Shot chapter drawn by
sweet Ishida which examines hisoka's
past whether that's actually Canon or
noted
but Togashi did approve the story for
for whatever that means the sad thing is
outside of that chapter we have no
images mauritonia however his aesthetic
can be surprisingly accurately summed up
by this mabarga card of magic manchi
because like I said there is a Machi for
All Occasions so mauritonio transmutes
Aura into magnetic 4 course which then
allows him to do all sorts of crazy crap
like walk on the walls on the ceilings
it's also implied that his Scarface
ability which is scarf Ace not Scarface
I only just realized I was a bit of a
pun there but it's also implied that his
Scarface ability is what inspired
hisoka's texture surprise because it's
the same thing but specifically with
faces in fact mauritonio is very much a
beta test for hisoka in general super
powerful incredibly intelligent but not
really reaching the full Heights of
transmutation so he's going to join
Machi in the a tier meanwhile here's
porcupine this is going to be a pretty
open and shut case he is a transmuter
who used exclusively enhancement and
manipulation so mate you are getting a
good old cast rowing for that which
brings us to sardiso a transmuter who I
would describe as having accomplished
the bare minimum after having both of
his arms served he then went on to
replace some of these funky nine
tentacles nentacles you replace them
with nentricles what he does on a very
basic level is extremely similar to
bungee gum except sandiso substance has
no properties of any note and also he is
transmuted far far too much or a volume
whereas hisoka goes for a more correct
precise volume although weirdly enough
sarso is even worse in the 1999 anime
because he still has both of his arms
the 1999 anime actually gets rid of the
disabilities of all of the heavens Arena
Trio even Guido the dude sells both of
his legs but the funniest is probably
real belt because instead of being bound
to a wheelchair and making the best of a
tragic situation he instead chooses I
repeat choosers to fight exclusively on
a Mobility Scooter back to satiso he's
pretty rubbish but at least he tried if
I was sanderson's almost certainly
disappointed teacher then I would give
him the bare minimum for a passing grade
which in this case is a seat here to
Silva zoldick now and we will not be
ranking him in this video nor will we be
ranking xenos older because Togashi
through a bit of a bombshell at us
recently revealing that these two are
both in fact emitters not transmuters
transmutation has taken a really heavy
loss with these two this used to be like
the Stacked affinity and now that
belongs to emitters but in honor of
their server us they will be recognized
all the way over here in there used to
be a transmutative to dessert now and
may I present you with a rather
unsatisfying souffle another hail Lee
member so so uh but at least one that
doesn't deny their own Affinity which
saves her from a Thora and I mean
thorough castroing but with the nothing
we know about her abilities and the
everything we know about her
inexperience with nen it is going to be
a d tier for now which brings us to
potentially the ultimate transmuter I
feel like I'm opening a pack of rare
cards inside of this pack could be
everything or nothing Well Fame power or
it could be nothing and it's worm so
it's nothing his ability is to burrow
through the ground like the regular one
it's not even transmuting anything he's
more like manipulating the dirt or
manipulating his body or both and I know
I said there was a manchy for All
Occasions but in this case the closest
to character has come to cosplaying worm
is actually illumi that one time that he
got in the hole but worm is a clear
Castor Contender and that is every
transmuter ranked arbitrarily by a man
on the internet